Automation anxiety has been spreading
lately fear that in the future many jobs
will be performed by machines rather
than human beings given the remarkable
advances that are unfolding in
artificial intelligence and robotics
what's clear is that there will be
significant change what's less clear is
what that change will look like my
research suggests that the future is
both troubling and exciting the threat
of technological unemployment is real
and yet it's a good problem to have and
to explain how I came to that conclusion
I want to confront three myths that I
think are currently obscuring our vision
of this automated future a picture that
we see on our television screens and
books and films and everyday commentary
is one where an army of robots descends
on the workplace with one goal in mind
to displace human beings from their work
and I call this the Terminator myth yes
machines displace human beings from
particular tasks but they don't just
substitute for human beings they also
complement them in other tasks making
that work more valuable and more
important sometimes they complement
human beings directly making them more
productive or more efficient at a
particular task
so a taxi driver can use a sat-nav
system to navigate on unfamiliar roads
an architect can use computer assisted
design software to design bigger more
complicated buildings but technological
progress doesn't just complement human
beings directly it also complements them
indirectly and it does this in two ways
the first is if we think of the economy
as a pie technological progress makes
the pie bigger as productivity increases
incomes rise and demand grows the
British pie for instance is more than a
hundred times the size it was 300 years
ago and so people displaced from tasks
in the old pie could find tasks to do in
the new pie instead
but technological progress doesn't just
make the pie bigger it also changes the
ingredients in the pie as time passes
people spend their income in different
ways changing how they spread it across
existing goods and developing tastes for
entirely new goods to new industries are
created new tasks have to be done and
that means often new roles have to be
filmed so again the British pie 300
years ago most people worked on farms
150 years ago in factories and today
most people work in offices and once
again people displaced from tasks in the
old bit of Pie could tumble into tasks
in the new bit of pie instead economists
call these effects complementarities but
really that's just a fancy word to
capture the different way that
technological progress helps human
beings resolving this Terminator myth
shows us that there are two forces at
play one machine substitution the harms
workers but also these complementarities
that do the opposite
now the second myth what I call the
intelligence myth what are the tasks of
driving a car making a medical diagnosis
and identifying a bird at a fleeting
glimpse have in common well these are
all tasks that until very recently
leading economists thought couldn't
readily be automated and yet today all
of these tasks can be automated
now all major car manufacturers have
driverless car programs there's
countless systems out there that can
diagnose medical problems and is even an
app that can identify a bird at a
fleeting glimpse now this wasn't simply
a case of bad luck on the part of
economists they were wrong and the
reason why they were wrong is very
important they'd fallen for the
intelligence myth the belief that
machines have to copy the way that human
beings think and reason in order to
outperform them when these economists
were trying to figure out what tasks
machines could not do they imagined the
only way to automate a task was to sit
down with a human being get them to
explain to you how it was they performed
a task and then try and capture that
explanation in a set of instructions for
a machine to follow this view is popular
in artificial intelligence at
point two I know this because Richard
Susskind who is my dad and my co-author
wrote his doctorate in the 1980s on
artificial intelligence and the law at
Oxford University and he was part of a
vanguard and with a professor called
Philip capper and a legal publisher
called Butterworth's they produced the
world's first artificial intelligent
system world's first commercially
available artificial intelligent system
in the law
this was the home screen design he
assures me this was a cool screen design
at the time I've never never been
entirely convinced he published it in
the form of two floppy disks time with
floppy disks genuinely were floppy and
his approach was the same as the
economists sit down with a lawyer get
her to explain to you how it was she
solved a legal problem and then try and
capture that explanation in a set of
rules for a machine to follow in
economics if human beings could explain
themselves in this way the tasks are
called routine and they could be
automated but if human beings can't
explain themselves the tasks are called
non routine and they're thought to be
out of reach today that routine non
routine distinctions widespread think
how often you hear people say to you
machines can only perform tasks that are
predictable or repetitive rules based or
well-defined
those are all just different words for
routine and go back to those three cases
that I mentioned at the start those are
all classic cases of non routine tasks
ask a doctor for instance how she makes
a medical diagnosis and she might be
able to give you a few rules of thumb
but ultimately she'd struggle she'd say
it requires things like creativity and
judgments and intuition and these things
are very difficult to articulate and so
it was thought these tasks would be very
hard to automate if a human being can't
explain themselves where on earth do we
begin in writing a set of instructions
for a machine to follow 30 years ago
this view was right but today it's
looking shaky and in the future it's
simply going to be wrong advances in
processing power in data storage
capability and an algorithm design mean
that this routine non routine
distinction is diminishing ly useful to
see this go back to the case of making a
medical diagnosis earlier in the year a
team of researchers
Stanford announced they developed a
system which can tell you whether or not
a freckle is cancerous as accurately as
leading dermatologists how does it work
it's not trying to copy the judgment or
the intuition of a doctor it knows or
understands nothing about medicine at
all instead it's running a pattern
recognition algorithm through a hundred
and twenty nine thousand four hundred
and fifty past cases hunting for
similarities between those cases and the
particular lesion in question it's
performing these tasks in an uncommon
way based on the analysis of more
possible cases than any doctor could
hope to review in their lifetime it
didn't matter that that human being that
doctor couldn't explain how she
performed the task now there are those
who dwell upon the fact that these
machines aren't built in our image as an
example take IBM's Watson the
supercomputer that went on the u.s. quiz
show Jeopardy in 2011 and it beat the to
human champions at jeopardy
the day after it won The Wall Street
Journal ran a piece by the philosopher
John Searle with the title Watson
doesn't know it won on Jeopardy right
and it's brilliant and it's true you
know Watson didn't let out a cry of
excitement it didn't call up its parents
to say what a good job it had done it
didn't go down to the pub for a drink
this system wasn't trying to copy the
way that those human contestants played
but it didn't matter it still outperform
them resolving the intelligence myth
shows us that our limited understanding
about human intelligence about how we
think and reason is far less of a
constraint on automation than it was in
the past what's more as we've seen when
these machines perform tasks differently
to human beings there's no reason to
think that what human beings are
currently capable of doing represents
any sort of summit in what these
machines might be capable of doing in
the future now the third myth once I
call the superiority myth it's often
said that those who forget about the
helpful side of technological progress
those complementarities from before are
committing something known as the lump
of Labor fallacy now the problem is the
lump of labor fallacy is itself a
fallacy and I call this the lump of
Labor fallacy fallacy or lot
for sure let me explain the lumber blade
the fallacy is a very old idea was a
british economist david schloss who gave
it this name in 1892 he was puzzled to
come across a dock worker who begun to
use a machine to make washers the small
metal disks that fasten on the end of
screws and this dock worker felt guilty
for being more productive now most the
time we expect the opposite that people
feel guilty for being unproductive a
little too much time on Facebook or
Twitter at work but this worker felt
guilty for being more productive and
asked why he said I know I'm doing wrong
I'm taking away the work of another man
in his mind there was some fixed lump of
work to be divided up between him and
his pals so that he used this machine to
do more there'd be less left for his
pals to do she last saw the mistake the
lump of work wasn't fixed as this worker
used the machine and became more
productive the price of washers would
fall demand for washers would rise more
washers would have to be made and
there'd be more work for his pals to do
the lump of work would get bigger
sloths called this the lump of labour
fallacy and today you hear people talk
about the lump of labour fallacy to
think about the future of all types of
work there's no fixed lump of work out
there to be divided up between people
and machines yes machines substitute for
human beings making the original lump of
work smaller but they also complement
human beings and the lump of work gets
bigger and changes but love here's the
mistake it's right to think that
technological progress makes the lump of
work to be done bigger some tasks become
more valuable and new tasks have to be
done but it's wrong to think that
necessarily human beings will be best
placed to perform those tasks and this
is the superiority myth yes the lump of
work might get bigger and change but as
machines become more capable it's likely
that they'll take on the extra lump of
work themselves technological progress
rather than complement human beings
complements machines instead to see this
go back to the task of driving a car
today sat-nav systems directly
complement human beings they make some
human beings better drivers but in the
future software's going to displace
human beings from the driving seat and
these
nav systems rather than complement human
beings will simply make these driverless
cars more efficient helping the machines
instead or go to those indirect
complementarities that I mentioned as
well the economic pie may get larger but
as machines become more capable it's
possible that any new demand will fall
on goods that machine's rather than
human beings the best place to produce
the economic pie may change but as
machines become more capable it's
possible that they'll be best placed to
do the new tasks that have to be done in
short demand for tasks isn't demand for
human labor human beings only stand to
benefit if they retain the upper hand in
all these complemented tasks but as
machines become more capable that
becomes less likely so what are these
three myths tell us then
well resolving the Terminator myths
shows us that the future of work depends
upon this balance between two forces one
machine substitution the harms workers
but also those complementarities that do
the officer and until now this balance
has fallen in favor of human beings but
resolving the intelligence myth shows us
that first force machine substitution is
gathering strength machines of course
can't do everything but they can do far
more encroaching ever deeper into the
realm of tasks performed by human beings
what's more there's no reason to think
that what human beings are currently
capable of represents any sort of
finishing line that machines are going
to draw to a polite stop once they're as
capable as us now none of this matters
so long as those helpful winds of
complementarity blow firmly enough but
resolving the superiority myth shows us
that that process of task encroachment
not only strengthens the force of
machine substitution but it wears down
those helpful complementarities to bring
these three myths together and I think
we can catch a glimpse of that troubling
future machines continue to become more
capable encroaching ever deeper on tasks
performed by human beings strengthening
the force of machine substitution
weakening the force of machine
complementarity and at some point that
balance falls in favor of machines
rather than human beings this is the
path we're currently on I say path
deliberately because I don't think we're
there yet
but it is hard to avoid the conclusion
that this is our direction of travel
that's the troubling parts let me say
now why I think actually this is a good
problem to have
for most of human history one economic
problem has dominated how to make the
economic pie large enough for everyone
to live on go back to the turn of the
first century AD and if you took the
global economic pie and divided it up
into equal slices for everyone in the
world everyone will get a few hundred
dollars now almost everyone lived on or
around the poverty line and if you
rolled forward a thousand years roughly
the same is true but in the last few
hundred years economic growth has taken
off those economic plies have exploded
in size global GDP per head the value of
those individual slices of the pie today
they're about ten thousand one hundred
and fifty dollars if economic growth
continues at two percent our children
will be twice as rich as us if it
continues that a more measly 1% our
grandchildren will be twice as rich as
us by and large we've solved that
traditional economic problem now
technological unemployment if it does
happen in a strange way will be a
symptom of that success we'll have
solved one problem
how to make the pie bigger but replaced
it with another how to make sure that
everyone gets a slice as other
economists have noted solving this
problem won't be easy today for most
people their job is there see to the
economic dinner table and in a world
with less work or even without work it
won't be clear how they get their slice
there's a great deal of discussion for
instance about various forms of
universal basic income as one possible
approach and there's trials underway in
the United States and in Finland and in
Kenya and this is the collective
challenge that's right in front of us to
figure out how this material prosperity
generated by our economic system can be
enjoyed by everyone in a world in which
our traditional mechanism for slicing up
the pie the work that people do withers
away and perhaps disappears solving this
problem is going to require us to think
in very different ways there's going to
be a lot of disagreement about what
ought to be done but it's important to
remember that this is a far better
problem to have
than the one that haunted our ancestors
for centuries how to make that pie big
enough in the first place thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]